you might know me from somewhere I'm
always nervous that I won't have enough
time to do my work I just want to be
left alone so I can get on with it when
people ask me to do things even go for a
walk in the park I'm always saying I
don't have enough time I have so much to
do so it's great when at last I've got a
clear day the house is quiet I've got
eight hours that should be plenty but
when there's so much time it seems silly
not to read article in the paper it's
about a celebrity he's got married she's
pretty
I might just look up what film she was
in on 9 mm interesting wonder mother
saying over on this website a volcano in
Indonesia Wow oh poor things I'd catch
it now it's hard stopped when there's
nothing else to do that sounds nice some
people say I should go out and take a
break why not go for a walk
bc i like to be near my work if i'm too
far
I get guilty but if I'm clearly well the
perfect distance for doing nothing is
when you have the constant chance to do
something it's a bit frightening to be
honest
someone told me in average life and he
has six hundred thousand hours in it so
many people around me are getting on
giving stuff but if you scare me too
much with all of this I get sad I lie
down and think I'm so hopeless there's
no point getting up I'm ashamed I don't
like myself very much it seems like I'm
lazy that's what everyone would say I
know but in truth I do nothing not
because I'm lazy but because I'm scared
I'm terrified if I start what I do will
be horrible
I won't think is so amazing and I know
they can't bake so it seems best not
even to begin what helps me the most is
when occasionally it feels like it
doesn't matter when it feels I can mess
up and that would be okay when the
pressure isn't so great like when I was
younger and there was less at stake it's
a bit to me inside you it's best to try
to understand me and not scare me with
perfection go gently once you've worked
out how I work you'll get a lot more
done
you